entschuldigung wissen sie wusste zum
bahnhof geht ja klar
kurzzeitig musste jetzt nach paris und
dann irgendwann premier und wir haben im
ersten ingo ist erst wieder da ist die
rot grün aber es ist eigentlich schon so
gut wie sie müssen dort 2 300 meter die
straße rauf dann nach rechts zu verbauen
sie kennen bestimmt ich komme könnten
sie vielleicht noch kurz eine bewertung
abgeben
es ist eine bewertung ob sie mit meiner
auskunft zufrieden waren
bis jetzt hat ja um eine auskunft okay
war und ihnen meine wegbeschreibung
weitergeholfen hat wir wollen was jetzt
wer wird wirt würden sie sagen sie sind
mit meiner leistung sehr zufrieden war
mal zu finden oder sind sie eventuell
noch verbesserungspotenzial mit spezies
die insassen oder wo es irgendwo nicht
weiterempfehlen würden sie mich in einer
ähnlichen situation noch einmal
ansprechen weil zugeht jetzt hat er auch
zeiten schwindet du du du du roudourou
lassen sie sich lieber von einem mann
oder von einer frau den weg erklären
möchte mir scheißegal bauen geblieben
auszubauen
weil zug das waren rund um 0 sind sie
jetzt sauer der freilich bin ist nicht
so wie man im zug versand auf einer
skala von 1 bis 10 sind die superstars
hersagen einmal sauertöpfisch oder mehr
so dass man jetzt care studies ist
wieder normal wie du oder server mit
drauf haben und wurde später über die
[Applaus]